[Music]  do you leave the lights on or the tv  when you fall asleep it's estimated that  about 40 percent of people do new  research suggests that's bad for your  heart according to a study from  northwestern medicine being exposed to  even moderate light when you're getting  some shut-eye can harm cardiovascular  function and increase insulin resistance  those are risk factors for heart disease  and diabetes  keeping where the lights on  your heart rate goes up  during the entire night while you're  sleeping and then the next day your  glucose measurements it showed that more  insulin had to be secreted to be able to  bring your glucose to a normal marble  so you can get some blackout shades or  wear one of those eye masks  light color does matter now they're  saying that red or orange is less  stimulating for the brain and if you  really need some light  she says keep it dim and close to the  floor so it's not near your eye yes